Luigi when we go back to the Italian
banking problem so the markets expect a
resolution a lot quicker than probably
what the EU needs to resolve it but is
this a bigger issue than brexit this
really be the final nail in the coffin
of the EU Fitz not solved in the right
way I think there is a risk I think that
the most likely scenario is is that
things will walk out but I think there
is a risk that if this doesn't work out
properly eventually we will create major
disruption in Italy and through that
probably in the entire European Union so
you wrote an article for a sort of into
Quattro basically saying you know this
is what the Atlantic front which was
considered too small by the markets but
still defended with teeth and grind by
the government and you would have
structured it differently what I what I
wrote is that I look at the the only one
big experience we have of a bad bank in
Italy which is the the Banco de Napoli
the banker denied monopoly went in a
deep crisis in 1996 and at the time nine
billion you are of loans were separated
in a entity called SGA and over 20 years
this SGA has recover most of actually
that money the problem is and many many
buddy use many people use this as an
example that we can get out of this
crisis just waiting and be patient
however if you look at how long it took
and how much it cost to get back that
money with reasonable interest rate
places the valued non-performing loan
around sort of twenty to twenty three
cents on the dollar which is much lower
than what Atlanta has evaluated them and
we'll put the Italian banking system in
a much weaker situation than people
perceive it to be in David you know this
as well I mean I this is a rough number
from the CFA Institute but within my
reading at the bottom is 18% is the
valuation and maybe it migrates up in
the 20s right where your 22% is I mean
this mystery of markdowns to me is a
all that much of a history when you
blend in all the history of markdowns we
get to that number don't you David
yeah and the problem with the asset
management company solution which has
been trying up the countries the biggest
problem with that when you actually move
these things off your balance you're a
bank you can basically move it up
whichever valuation to basically render
the the good banks off and so to speak
so I think there is a lack of
transparency in that transfer process
and small but I think the bigger issue
here is for European banks is the fact
that you know what we've seen a massive
increase in correlation between European
bank stocks this year and with German
government bond yields and that's
telling you the market for the first
time is starting to question the
effectiveness of further monetary easing
because Altamonte reason is doing
driving down yields is waking the banks
and then in Europe this is a huge
problem because of the disproportion of
role that European banks would credit I
would point out to the Economist
Francine Lacroix this morning brought up
five-year gilts which is doing the same
thing yeah and actually David I want to
go back to your points that's the is it
even worse for European banks that the
ECB has gone into negative territory
than it is for Japanese banks absolutely
I think if you look at our should be
because the point here is in Europe you
know unlike the US for example either
the UK for that matter it's much more
dependent on banks and it's basically
lenders so from my point of view waking
the banks and then the banks are
reluctant to recapitalize what you're
gonna end up with is basically credit
crunch which i think is what you're
seeing in Europe but the credit crunch
goes Luigi to the heart of the matter
everybody knows this go out and raise
more money and dilute equity
shareholders
what is your Italy waiting for we know
that first of all equity holders don't
want to be diluted we've seen that in
the United States during the crisis
everybody was waiting so the question is
is the government willing to step in and
force this will capitalization one way
or another and that the answer is I
don't think so I've been actually trying
to advocate and move in this direction
but that's in that doesn't seem to be
political will at this moment to do so